is there something you could say just on
a small tangent
about
really impressive ai
from a game design
human enjoyment perspective
really impressive ai that you've seen in
games and maybe what does it take to
create ai system and how hard of a
problem is that so a million questions
yeah
just as a brief tangent
well look i think um
games uh games have been significant in
my life for three reasons so first of
all to to i was playing them and
training myself on games when i was a
kid then i went through a phase of
designing games and writing ai4 games so
all the games i i professionally wrote
uh had ai as a core component and that
was mostly in the in the 90s and the
reason i was doing that in games
industry was at the time the games
industry i think was the cutting edge of
technology so whether it was graphics
with people like john carmack and quake
and those kind of things or ai i think
actually all the action was going on in
games and and we've seen we're still
reaping the benefits of that even with
things like gpus which you know i find
ironic was obviously invented for
graphics computer graphics but then
turns out to be amazingly useful for ai
it just turns out everything's a matrix
multiplication it appears you know in
the way in the whole world yes so um so
i think games at the time had the most
cutting edge ai and a lot of the the
games uh we you know i was involved in
writing so there was a game called black
and white which was one game i was
involved with in the early stages of
which i still think is the most um
impressive uh example of reinforcement
learning in a computer game so in that
game you know you trained a little pet
animal uh and brilliant yeah and it sort
of learned from how you were treating it
so if you treated it badly then it
became mean yeah and then it would be
mean to to your villagers and your and
your population the sort of uh the
little tribe that you were running uh
but if you were kind to it then it would
be kind and people were fascinated by
how that worked and so was i to be
honest with the way it kind of developed
and um especially the mapping to good
and evil yeah it made you made you
realize made me realize that you can
sort of in the way in the choices you
make can define
uh the where you end up and that means
all of us are capable of the good
uh evil it all matters in the different
choices along the trajectory to those
places that you make it's fascinating i
mean games can do that philosophically
to you and it's rare it seems rare yeah
well games are i think a unique medium
because um you as the player you're not
just passively consuming the the the
entertainment right you're actually
actively involved as an as a as an agent
so i think that's what makes it in some
ways can be more visceral than other
other mediums like you know films and
books so the second so that was you know
designing ai and games and then the
third use uh uh i've we've used of ai is
in deep mind from the beginning which is
using games as a testing ground for
proving out ai algorithms and developing
ai algorithms and that was a that was a
sort of um a core component of our
vision at the start of deep mind was
that we would use games very heavily uh
as our main testing ground certainly to
begin with um because it's super
efficient to use games uh and also you
know it's very easy to have metrics to
see how well your systems are improving
and what direction your ideas are going
in and whether you're making incremental
improvements
and because those games are often rooted
in something that humans did for a long
time beforehand there's already a strong
set of rules like it's already a damn
good benchmark yes it's really good for
so many reasons because you've got
you've got you've got clear measures of
how good humans can be at these things
and in some cases like go we've been
playing it for thousands of years um and
and uh often they have scores or at
least win conditions so it's very easy
for reward learning systems to get a
reward it's very easy to specify what
that reward is um and uh also at the end
it's easy to you know to test externally
you know
how strong is your system by of course
playing against you know the world's
strongest players at those games so it's
it's so good for so many reasons and
it's also very efficient to run
potentially millions of simulations in
parallel on the cloud so um i think
there's a huge reason why we were so
successful back in you know starting out
2010 how come we were able to progress
so quickly because we'd utilize games
and um you know at the beginning of deep
mind we also hired some amazing game
engineers uh who i knew from my previous
uh lives in the games industry and uh
and that helped to bootstrap us very
quickly and plus it's somehow super
compelling almost at a philosophical
level
of man versus machine
over over a chessboard or a go board
and especially given that the entire
history of ai is defined by people
saying it's going to be impossible to
make a machine that
beats a human being in chess
and then once that happened
people were certain when i was coming up
in ai that go
is not a game that could be solved
because of the combinatorial complexity
it's just too it's it's it's you know
no matter how much moore's law you have
compute is just never going to be able
to crack the game of go yeah and so that
then there's something compelling about
facing sort of taking on the
impossibility of that task from the
ai
researcher perspective engineer
perspective and then as a human being
just observing this whole thing
your
beliefs about what you thought was
impossible
being broken apart
it's it's uh humbling
to realize we're not as smart as we
thought
it's humbling to realize that the things
we think are impossible now perhaps will
be done
in the future there's something
really powerful about a game
ai system being a human being in a game
that drives that message
uh home for like millions billions of
people especially in the case of go
you